- Scarlett Johansson makes a second,
I think more interesting, argument
in her suit against Disney.
She's claiming that Disney
breached what's called
the Covenant of Good
Faith and Fair Dealing.
Generally, the Covenant of Good
Faith and Fair Dealing says
that apart from the actual
language of the contract,
you can't do things that uphold
the letter of the contract
while frustrating the
intent of the contract.
So for example, if I was
going to enter a new contract
to sell all Apple computers,
and then I wanted back
out of the contract,
and I just rebranded all my
computers Schmapple computers
and said, "Well, look,
"we don't make Apple computers anymore.
"We only make Schmapples."
Well, that might not be an actual breach
of the language of the contract,
but you can see that that violates
the Covenant of Good
Faith and Fair Dealing.
That's what ScarJo says
happened with Disney.
Scarlett Johansson only made extra money
based on the theatrical release,
and if they're going to release
this thing on Disney Plus
where they make $60 million
instead of the $20 million,
well, then she doesn't
see any value to that
and that frustrates the
Covenant of Good Faith
and Fair Dealing.
This could potentially
be a better argument
than her pure breach of contract claim,
but regardless, we'll see them in court.